sometimes the libs accuse conservatives
of exaggerating our problems for
political gain especially when it comes
to the so-called social issues
that's why it's helpful when we can just
play clips of the libs in their own
words
the woman you're about to hear is named
christy olazewski
she is a quack doctor but she's not a
fringe quack doctor
she is a professor and practitioner at
the yale school of medicine she heads up
yale's pediatric gender program
her job is to convince three-year-olds
to begin a lifelong process of chemical
injections and genital mutilations to
make them look more like the opposite
sex
i'm a clinical psychologist by training
and i am the director of the yale gender
program which is an interdisciplinary
program
working with gender expansive
individuals three to 25 and their
families we
help individuals who are questioning
their gender identity or who identify as
transgender or non-binary we help them
with their gender journey thinking
through that thinking through the risks
and the benefits of
medical intervention
starting medical intervention
and also building supports around them i
love what i do so it's really really
wonderful to
to be working in this field and to be
working with individuals who are gender
diverse and gaining their support and
helping them on their gender journeys
3 to 25
this woman works with individuals ages
3
to 25
to facilitate their gender journeys
three
the wildest predictions of the most
alarmist religious right leaders of the
past several decades
did not predict this the slipperiest
slippery slope warnings did not predict
the ivy league
grooming three-year-olds to turn into
castrati mutants
our nation's mainstream liberal
institutions not just the crazy radicals
the actual
mainstream as establishment as it gets
yale university have become
more extreme than any of us could have
possibly imagined
and the more predatory and outright
demonic that the leftists get
the more insistent they become
that it's us conservatives who have
changed that it's us conservatives who
pose the threat to the country that it's
us conservatives who must be stopped by
any means necessary and do not doubt for
one second
people who gleefully sterilize toddlers
will attack their opponents using any
means necessary i'm michael knowles
that's the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from mark
mcconville who says my wife suggested a
drinking game every time michael says
libs i now have a serious buzz halfway
through the video oh yeah you'll be dead
by the end of the video because libs it
just sums it all up some people want
these really serious self-serious terms
a very specific term actually it should
be progressives actually i'm you should
talk about the leftists actually that's
just the libs they're just the libs
the libs are the libs the more things
change the more they stay the same okay
we got to reach people and we've got to
use really simple clear terms when you
want to reach people you got to check
out podium right now go to podium.com
knowles if you own a business you know
the last two years have not been easy
from supply chain issues to increased
demand on top of everything else that
business owners have to manage the
businesses that are thriving right now
are the ones that are forward thinking
podium helps your small business stay
ahead of the curve with modern messaging
tools that make it easy for your
customers to connect with your business
from healthcare providers to plumbers
over 100 000 businesses are texting with
customers through podium customers love
the convenience businesses love the
results with podiums all in one inbox
you can do even more than just chat you
can get online reviews by sending an
easy to use link you can collect
payments fast from anywhere you can send
marketing campaigns that actually get
response and it's so simple you do it
all by sending a quick text
see how your podium can grow your
business watch a demo today at
podium.com knowles that is podium.com
knowles podium
let's grow
these pediatric gender clinics are
cropping up everywhere there's one right
here in tennessee tennessee right in our
backyard at vanderbilt pediatric gender
clinic
absolutely horrifying stuff obviously
should be shut down obviously this lady
at yale kristy olazewski and all of the
other psychos who are working with her
to trans three-year-olds these people
should all be in prison
first we have to pass a law
banning this stuff for first they need
to lose their jobs then we need to pass
a law banning this stuff and then the
second these people continue to groom
the little kids and you know they will
we need to put them in orange jumpsuits
and it's just as simple as that
this is spreading like wildfire like a
social contagion and it's specifically
targeted at little kids and it's not
just coming from
the pervert in the white van sitting
in the bad part of the neighborhood okay
it's not just coming from some sex
trafficker
international criminal it's not just
coming from the child porn producer it's
coming from yale
it's coming from new york's fashion week
here's a story out of new york
a 10 year old child has just become the
youngest transgender model to walk the
runway
at new york's fashion week
this young boy
goes by noella
he participated in the trans clothing
company show this was created by the
designer mel atkinson this according to
metro
and noella this little boy who who's
who the adults in his life are dressing
up to be a little girl
says it feels good that i'm already
inspiring trans kids to be themselves
now obviously what transgenderism does
is the opposite they encourage kids and
all people not to be themselves to be
other people or to pretend to be other
people to have a little boy pretend to
be a little girl or vice versa i'm all
for encouraging people to be themselves
and not even just themselves as they are
but to be a perfect good version of
themselves
all people can they can go bad or they
can go good they can get into a lot of
vice and sin and bad stuff or they can
do good stuff pursue virtue sanctity
holiness
and we should we should encourage the
latter not the former it's not just that
you're born
some people are born good some people
are born bad that's not true we have
free will we have a conception of what's
good and what's bad
okay and we and we can know something
about that and pursue that here we're
getting the worst possible version we're
encouraging people to only pursue really
bad stuff and then to just pretend to be
totally different than they are outright
how on earth does a 10 year old kid wind
up doing a drag dance at new york
fashion week obviously because this poor
little boy has pervert parents
his current guardians that's how it's
described in the article
i don't even know what the relationship
of these adults are to the kid i just
know that they're perverts rey and dee
mcmahor
told a metro
that noella who's this little boy began
socially transitioning at the age of
four
so you so you read then you say rey and
d that sounds like normal people right
but i know they're not normal people
because they're transiting their little
four-year-old so of course these guys
are both guys or girls i don't know what
they are are both sexual deviants they
identify as non-binary and so whose
fault is this the primary fault is the
fault of the parents
or i don't know the parents the current
guardians as this is ambiguously
described in the paper
but the parents are the fault of us
that's really what this is about we
can't just say those guys are perverts
or girls or whatever they are we can't
just say they're perverts they're this
is their child abuse yeah it is they're
primarily responsible but we let this
happen
we let this happen how on earth did
these people adopt a child or do it or
through surrogacy create a child right i
actually don't know if it's two guys or
two girls or a guy and a girl the fact
that i don't know that is our fault
politically because we've radically
redefined marriage so we have no idea
what marriage means we tolerate all
sorts of sexual degeneracy so men can
pretend to be women and women can be
pretend to be men and they can pretend
to be ambiguous people are having a
surgery called sexual nullification that
means they just chop off their genitals
entirely and we tolerate this not only
do we tolerate this we celebrate this
and if you in any way criticize it
you're called a hater and you can be
ostracized from society i'm not sure
that this video will remain on youtube
you know i broadcast my show in part on
youtube i'm not sure that this will even
be allowed to be kept up
because i don't think that these pervs
should be allowed within 300 yards of a
child and i don't think they should be
able to pretend that their union is a
marriage and i don't think they should
be able to pretend that
whichever one of them is a man
either or none of them as a man is a
girl or vice versa or that they're
neither
that's our fault we let it get this far
we in the political community
we let the libs go this far because so
many conservatives what did they say
well it doesn't affect me
i think government should get out of the
marriage business entirely well i don't
know what people do in their bedroom
between consenting adults that's none of
my business i don't i think this is my
business i don't want kids on drag on
drag
red carpets i don't want kids little
boys dancing around like little girls
for the satisfaction of perverts at new
york's fashion week i don't want these
yale psychopaths to be able to trans
three-year-olds
i think that's a political problem
that's why the government's always
involved in marriage by the way because
marriage is the fundamental political
institution and the state meaning the
political community obviously has an
interest and obviously always has some
kind of say in how to raise the next
generation
that's what it is that's what marriage
is marriage is a lifelong bond a union
between a man and a woman for the sake
of the generation the procreation and
the education of children
we have a say about that
or we should
or we just let this
we let this go
and i do i blame the libs
but i expected of the libs
really here my my special ire is for
those squishy conservatives
who let it get this far because they
didn't have the moral clarity or even if
they did have the moral clarity in a lot
of cases they didn't have the moral
courage to say no
sorry ray and d mcmahor you don't get to
pretend that your non-binary union is a
marriage and you don't get to either
purchase a child or adopt a child or
rent a woman's womb and create a child
in this way that establishes the
domination of technology over the origin
and destiny of the human person and you
it's not about you you don't get to do
your weird stuff sorry there are rules
and standards and we are going to defend
them when you want to
have a good political order you need to
communicate this stuff clearly when you
want to communicate you've got to check
out pure talk right now go to
puretalk.com enter promo code knowles
podcast thanks to bite inflation you are
paying way more money than you should
for gas for groceries polls show that 94
of americans are upset or concerned
about the impact of rising prices
obviously 95 believe that soaring
inflation is very or somewhat serious as
a result of this every business is
trying to nickel and dime you how much
can they squeeze out of you to offset
their increasing costs every business
except for pure talk pure talk gives you
talk text and plenty of data for just 30
per month
no price increase there you're probably
paying 90 bucks a month for your current
cell phone plan i am a pure talk
customer they are incredibly reliable i
know everyone's so hesitant to switch
cell phone plans even if they hate their
cell phone company i was that way too
and then i got pure talk and i got it on
a nice new apple iphone and i'll tell
you the 5g coverage is great
the switch is super duper easy you can
do it in 10 minutes
right now pure talk is offering their
best discount ever just to our listeners
one month free
lock in that talk text data on america's
most reliable 5g network for just 30
bucks a month plus
one month free when you make the switch
today puretalk.com enter promo code
knowles podcast for this special offer
that is puretalk.com promo code noel's
podcast
speaking of fashion there is a pastor in
kansas city i'm going to use that term
pastor loosely i don't know what kind of
bizarre sect this guy is a pastor of but
he calls himself a pastor he's got some
sort of flock in kansas city and he's
very upset at his congregation
because his congregation
would not buy him an expensive movado
watch
see that's how i know you still poor
broke busted and disgusted because of
how you've been honoring me
i'm not worthy of mcdonald's money
i'm not worth your red lobster money
i ain't worth your saint john nick
y'all can't afford it know-how
i ain't worth y'all louis vuitton
i ain't worth your prada
i'm not worth your gucci
mother oh i'm saying this and i promise
your dignity is not with respect and
won't i'm saying it because i want you
to understand just what god is saying
you can buy a movado watch in sam's yes
and y'all know i asked for one last year
here it is the whole way in august i
still ain't got it y'all ain't saying
nothing let me kick down the door and
talk to my cheap sons and daughters
[Music]
so i really get a kick out of this guy i
know what he's doing is evil but i
really it gave me a great idea because i
don't want a movado movado i find is a
little too modernist it's a little too
but but i would like a patek philippe
watch and they're you know look they're
a bargain you can get those for anywhere
from what
twenty thousand dollars to a few million
and so
i think this guy can do it to his flock
here i
we've got there are a lot of listeners
out there what you you listeners out
there you're too cheap to buy me a patek
philippe watch you're listening to this
show every day
every single day i'm sitting here you
know i want
a nice two hundred thousand dollar patek
philippe watch and you're too cheap
you're too busted
to buy me that watch you would probably
be pretty offended if i said that i
would like the watch by the way but you
would probably be pretty pretty offended
if if i said that
and rightly so and you would have the
right to be much much more offended if i
were speaking as a pastor i mean that
guy is dressed up like a priest he's
obviously not a priest but he puts on
the uniform of a priest he has a little
collar a fake collar or some whatever
fake religious orders this guy took
and he's using that
from the position of a wolf in sheep's
clothing which is very specifically
warned about in the bible and he's
trying to fleece his flock to buy him
nice jewelry
we tend to have a more visceral and
negative reaction to guys like this
even than we do
to
the atheists even than we do to the
radicals perhaps even then we do to the
blasphemers and the heretics and the
libs i guess this guy is a heretic
but we
we have a more visceral visceral
reaction to people who pretend to be
on our side
but are actually coming from the
position of our enemies and our
opponents
this actually explains why the
conservatives are so revved up against
liz cheney
because if you just look at voting
record
is liz cheney worse than nancy pelosi no
of course not even close if you if you
just looked at voting record
liz cheney is more conservative than her
replacement in the house leadership
elise stefanik at elise stefanik has a
much more liberal voting record than liz
cheney
now you might say ellie stefanik is from
new york she's got a more liberal
district liz shady
from wyoming but whatever that's just if
you look at the
at the voting record
but liz cheney
puts on the republican skin
puts on the republican collar and
uniform
as a wolf in sheep's clothing is every
time it matters
every time there's a vote that counts
she sides with the libs john mccain used
to do this john mccain talked a good
game he sided with the republicans he
even sided with trump whom he hated i
think 83 to 85 percent of the time even
trump
and yet on the crucial votes on the
obamacare vote the vote that he john
mccain ran his last campaign saying i
will vote against obamacare i will vote
to overturn obamacare and when it comes
to that moment john mccain walks into
the room into the senate he's going to
be the deciding vote he votes no
wolves
in sheep's clothing
and we react
naturally and i think rightly against
this because we understand that betrayal
is a very very bad sin dante keeps
coming up this week in dante's inferno
in hell
the lowest sin the absolute pit of hell
that you find satan frozen in a lake of
ice
is
betrayal specifically the betrayal of
one's benefactors at the bottom of hell
you've got this three-headed satan
gnawing on three people in in the three
heads
judas
brutus and cassius people who betray
their benefactors judas obviously who
betrays christ
that's why we react against that
and we're right to do not
betray your flock do not lead one of the
little ones astray there's that verse in
the new testament where christ is saying
people who lead
even
any of these little ones into sin who
cause even these little ones to stumble
it would be better for that man to have
millstones tied around his neck and very
often this verse is misinterpreted as
talking about physically attacking a
little one or abortion maybe killing a
little one but it's actually causing the
little one to stumble it's actually
referring to scandal it's referring to
wolves and sheep's clothing coming in
and betraying their mission and
betraying their flock and leading people
astray
don't do that don't do it for a movado
watch
don't do it for a nice plush
profile in the new york times don't do
it for a cushy gig on msnbc or cnn
speaking of religion one of the most
famous or infamous
new atheists of the 2000s
sam harris the new atheists for those
who don't remember was sam harris
christopher hitchens richard dawkins and
daniel dennett
and it was more of publishing phenomenon
than it was a real intellectual movement
but it was a bunch of guys who said
religion is bad and they did it because
they were attacking islam because
radical islam was a big topic of concern
then after 9 11 and they used the
specifics of islamic terror attacks to
attack religion generally and a bunch of
very shallow thinking teenagers thought
this was really smart i was one of those
shallow thinking teenagers i was really
taken up by it the new atheists have
aged like milk and now the new atheists
are not even being applauded by the libs
because they've transgressed certain
norms of wokeness and
political correctness
but it's worth remembering these guys
doc hitchens is dead but dawkins
dennett and
sam harris
these are even though they sometimes
contradict political correctness they
are men of the left sam harris just
proved this when in an interview he said
look
yeah it's bad that the
liberal oligarchy twitter and big tech
it's bad that they covered up the hunter
biden laptop story and they censored the
new york post and they stopped people
from messaging the story which was
damaging to the bidens to one another
that's bad but you know look it was to
stop trump so yeah sends her away at
that point hunter biden literally could
have had had the corpses of children in
his basement
i would not have cared right it's like
it's there's nothing first of all it's
hunter biden right it's not it's like
it's not joe biden but even if joe like
even whatever scope of joe biden's
corruption is like if you if we could
just go down that rabbit hole endlessly
and and
understand that he's getting kickbacks
from hunter biden's deals in ukraine or
whatever else right or china
it is
infinitesimal
compared to the corruption we know trump
is involved in now that's not that
doesn't answer the people who say it's
still completely unfair
to not have looked at the laptop in a
timely way and to have shut down the you
know the new york post's twitter account
like that that's just a conspiracy
left-wing conspiracy to deny the
presidency to donald trump
absolutely it was absolutely right but i
think it was warranted
it was a left-wing conspiracy it was
censorship it was wrong
maybe it was illegal i don't know
but who cares it was all sorts of sin
sinful and all sorts of terrible but it
was worth it
so on the surface this story is not that
interesting wow one of the most famous
atheists in america is advocating
immorality not exactly
a man bites dog story of course the guy
has no real solid moral foundation he
has tried to create some way of
justifying the existence of objective
morality without god that is a fool's
errand that's not possible so when push
comes to shove when it gets to something
he really really wants like kicking
trump out of office he says yeah the
ends justify the means it's immoral but
whatever you know who cares
sure
sure
the bigger takeaway here
is that the libs will do
anything to stop trump and his
supporters even sam harris
sam harris by today's standards is one
of the more moderate libs and even he
says yeah
do anything to stop trump because they
called trump hitler they said trump is
hitler trump is the embodiment of evil
and so if they use that kind of language
for trump and his supporters and you and
me folks
and anyone to the right of hillary
clinton if they use that kind of
language then of course they will do
absolutely anything to stop us we can't
be surprised when people who kill the
babies and trans the kids and rig
elections and censor all sorts of
material and who admit that these things
are immoral when they do those sorts of
things we cannot be surprised there's
nothing they won't do to stop the evil
orange man
with the daily wires rapid growth
we cannot hire fast enough we are
actively looking to expand our team and
add some new jobs to this non-recession
economy
i suggested we hire a dedicated team of
cigar rollers unfortunately that was
overruled for now which is absolutely
outrageous i'm looking for new
employment as a result of that i just
don't feel supported here okay
if i can't have a delicious stuff anyway
the daily wire is currently looking to
hire exceptional performers to join our
wonderful ad revenue team
if you have experience in digital
advertising audio sales and campaign
optimization and client services we
would
love to hear from you right now if you
know how to roll a proper cigar that is
even better i would like to hear from
you right now go to dailywire.com
careers view our openings and apply
dailywire.com
careers
the libs will go to any length to stop
trump and
by trump we mean
you and me and all the conservatives
trump is a symbol trump is a vessel all
political candidates are to some degree
symbols and vessels and trump and he
said this himself he said they're not
just coming after me they're only coming
after me because they want to get to you
and i happen to be in the way i'm the
representative of you that's why they're
going after me
it's not just msnbc and cnn it's not
just the online atheist authors and
public intellectuals
it's the deep state
okay the rea the actual deep state
it's the blob it's the whole liberal
establishment starting with the media
and big tech as the publishing platform
of the media the publishing platform of
the publishing platforms you saw a tweet
that came out just the other day from
edward loose
edward lewis is an associate editor of
financial times very mainstream
established paper he says i've covered
extremism and violent ideologies around
the world over my career have never come
across a political force more nihilistic
dangerous and contemptible than today's
republicans nothing close a ridiculous
statement which we'll get to in one
second but the real kicker here is that
insane comment was retweeted by
the former cia director michael hayden
michael hayden says i agree and i was
the cia director and by the way michael
hayden wasn't obama's cia director
michael hayden was
george w bush's cia director he was a
republican appointee albeit from the
liberal wing of the republican party the
bushes going all the way back to grand
daddy prescott have come from the
liberal wing of the republican party
this is why reagan and bush were a team
together because they ran against one
another in the primaries in 1980 because
reagan represented the conservative wing
of the party and the bush george h.w
bush represented the liberal wing
general michael hayden military
background cia background
he agrees with the statement
that today's republicans
are the most
nihilistic
dangerous and contemptible force
ever that they've ever seen in the whole
wide world
not just in america isis
oh nothing compared to the republicans
al qaeda
the chinese communist party
mean mr putin
even i thought putin was the worst guy
ever no no not compared to
ron desantis i guess not compared to ted
cruz i suppose certainly not compared to
trump
now it makes of course no sense the
the only political group that i would
apply the term nihilistic to
in in america would be
the left
the left to be nihilistic is to
believe that nothing really means
anything at all to be just absolutely
totally black-pilled and just want to
burn it down first of all the libs
literally burn the country down but
furthermore they're chopping up little
kids right now because they don't think
our bodies really have meaning or don't
really have an objective kind of
intrinsic meaning they're chopping up
little kids they're killing babies 850
000 a year they're they're trying to
assassinate supreme court justices who
are in any way threatening their right
to kill babies
they're upending our institutions
they're defending rigging elections
they're defending censorship if you're
going to call anyone nihilistic it's so
bizarre to accuse the the republicans
who say hey you know hey guys would it
be possible we're not even going to
outlaw all abortions do we just like
have
slightly fewer every year
i have never seen a more extreme
holistic date hey guys would it be look
if we're going to chop off people's uh
appendages and stuff and and pump them
full of hormones and turn them into
castrati can we wait until they're i
don't know like five i've never seen a
more extreme
evil
dangerous ah hey guys you know could we
you know marriage you know it's
fundamental in the unit of society could
we you know how there was a definition
of it for all of human history
everywhere
until uh like five minutes ago maybe
i've never seen a more extreme
you ah
you probably don't even want us to go to
monkeybox orgies well okay all right
fine that's what they say that's what
they believe
michael hayden is not just some crazy
blue check he is a crazy blue jack
he is a lib i guess but he
the guy was the cia director okay
the guy was a general
this stuff
is in institutions that wield
extraordinary
covert
clandestine often abused unaccountable
power against you
they're telling you that when people
tell you what they're doing
you should believe them
so what do the republicans do in this
case
elon musk has an idea and i get a real
kick out of elon musk the guy's doing a
lot of good in many ways in the world
but this one was a head scratcher
elon musk was asked by a donor what the
republican party needs to do better
and elon musk said that the gop needs to
be more compassionate on immigration
he says that that the gop needs to be
more compassionate to potential
newcomers and he noted that
this is
he believes this in part because he
chose america for its opportunities he
says immigrants are vital to maintaining
a dynamic economy
how much more welcoming to newcomers can
we be
we let in millions of people every year
we allow one million people to come into
this country every year legally and
almost no one is even challenging that
even though the vast majority of the
american people on poll after poll
reflect and express that they want to
drastically reduce the number of legal
immigrants who are brought into this
country by about 60 percent
still no one in either of the major
parties really talks about that
very few people
then on top of the million legal
immigrants we allow in every year we
allow 2 million illegal immigrants it's
probably going to be more than that this
year under biden and we've done this for
decades now the numbers have increased
pretty dramatically recently but we've
allowed
untold
masses of foreign nationals to pour into
our country and then we give them all
kinds of goodies and we give them all
kinds of resources and we allow them to
participate in our government we give
them the rights of citizens in many
cases
how much more compassionate can we be
i think
i think we've been a little maybe a
little overly compassionate not
compassionate enough to our own citizens
i think we've been a little reckless
actually and imprudent
how much more compassionate can you
possibly
be this is an issue of meta-politics
this is not just an issue of the
immigrants it's an issue of
meta-politics
the movement of immigrants into america
over the past
60 years or so is the largest
migration of people
ever in recorded history
how much more compassionate can we be
what that does is it changes our
political landscape the reason the
democrats encourage this the reason the
democrats changed all our immigration
laws
is because they feel
that by changing the makeup of the
country the actual people in the country
they will get an electoral advantage and
the data bear that out maybe not as much
of an advantage as they think that
they're getting
but it will give them an advantage a
generational advantage as well and they
know it and they brag about it and
they've been bragging about this in
academic papers and in the mainstream
media for 20 years now
and the republicans are supposed to
what go even more in that direction i
don't think so that's called not only is
that reckless not only is that wrong
politically it's also suicidal
you know our mailbag
is sponsored by puretalk you know how
much i absolutely adore pure talk go to
pure talk today select a plan enter
promo code knowles podcast to get one
month free
let's first before we get to the written
mail bag let's get to
the voicemail back
hey michael i listened to you on
benchmark show the other day and you got
to the mailbag part where you're talking
about how
we shouldn't give the death penalty to
rapists because that would incentivize
them to kill their victims
but
i feel like that's contradictory to
things you've said in the past about how
laws
affect people's behavior because
culture's downstream of politics
and if you make harsher punishments for
crimes then that makes people less
likely to do crime
so
why shouldn't we make harsher
punishments for rape i.e capital
punishment death penalty
so that less people would rape
but you said on ben shapiro show that it
wouldn't well you didn't say it wouldn't
do crease rape you just said it would
incentivize people to kill their victims
but the implication there is that it
wouldn't decrease the amount of rapes it
would just increase the amount of people
who are raped and murdered can you
explain that to me
well you were on the show thank you very
much you were right up until that very
moment and you even caught yourself and
you said well okay you didn't say that
it wouldn't uh
decrease rape but you know but the
implication was but no the
your implication the thing that you
inferred is not something that i implied
yes it is true harsher punishments for
rape would disincentivize rape
and because the law is a teacher you
would get less rape sure
but at the same time simultaneously you
would incentivize the rapists who do
commit rape to kill their victims if the
punishment for murder and the punishment
for rape were the same because
the rapist
in a regime in which rape is punished
less severely than murder the rapist has
some incentive not to kill his victim
even though by not killing his victim he
increases the chances that he'll be
caught because the victim could go to
the police and say what happened
but in a regime in which rape and murder
get the exact same punishment then the
the rapist has absolutely no incentive
whatsoever other than his own obviously
malfunctioning conscience or the
conscience that he doesn't really listen
to not to murder his victim so you
create an incentive for the rapist to do
that
so what we have here is a balancing of
different incentives and different
desirable outcomes
and what we have to apply here is
prudence
i agree
if if you gave the death penalty to
rapists you might
and very likely would reduce the total
number of rapes you would never get the
total number of rapes to zero but you
you probably would reduce the number of
rapes but you would increase the number
of rape victims who are murdered and i
don't think that's worth the cost
so from the position of prudence
i would say it is worth reducing
somewhat the punishment for rape
if you are going to decrease the number
of rape victims who are murdered
even if
by doing so you somewhat increase the
incentives to commit a rape
or the prevalence of rape again i mean
we're
we can't really know the degree to which
these things would shift statistically
but even granting the premise i just
think from a prudential point of view by
decreasing the number of rape victims
who are murdered that would be worth
tolerating
getting rid of one of the disincentives
to rape but it's a it's a judgment call
it's a call for prudence it's not an
exact science that's why states craft
statecraft rather is much more of an art
than it is a sort of science that can
just be plugged into a computer and
formulated by a robot next question
hey mike congratulations on the new
little bundle of joy hope it's keeping
you up all night
and
have a question of utmost importance for
you this is
quite literally potentially a matter of
life and death it is that important
are you
a soda
or a pop kind of guy
or
are you one of those crazy psychopaths
that calls everything
coke
yeah
inquiring minds need to know thanks
soda
the correct answer is soda
i agree with you the absolute decadent
maniacs who refer to all different sodas
as coke all of a sprite coke
that
they cannot be helped i don't know how
to reach those people but i call it soda
because i grew up on the coasts grew up
in new york we call it soda we're not
we're not nice wholesome midwestern
people there we don't call it pop we
call it soda
although these days i don't drink a lot
of soda
i drink silly seltzer water because i'm
a millennial
i drink black coffee
i drink
i drink you know something a little more
exciting so a little more similar to a
coca-cola but not a soda
later on after dinner and
occasionally when i'm feeling
sweet and saucy i will drink an egg
cream soda but all the time it's always
a soda not pop next question
hey michael
so
i have a funny story that kind of
relates to what you were talking about
in a previous episode
so in 2012 i believe when obama was
running
a
felon from i think it was texas
beat him in
a lot of west virginia counties like it
was 40 60 like it was really close made
me laugh
complete topic change right here my
sister who's been struggling with
infertility um
we were talking she asked me how i felt
about roe versus wade
i said i 110 agree it shouldn't have
even been decided in the first place
like it was great that it was overturned
and she said
i agree abortion should never be used as
birth control because
you know women are responsible for their
actions right
and then we got to the topic of rape
she said
and i quote if i went out today
got raped and got pregnant
me being infertile
i would 100 no questions ask it an
abortion
that made no sense to me and then she
got really mad at me when i said
execute the rapist don't execute baby
the baby had nothing to do with it
um
so we went back and forth and then she
got really mad at me but
i mean we're still cordial like i'm
close with my sister but
yeah that argument made absolutely no
sense
thank you
a good point yes the argument doesn't
make sense but it's one that i've i've
found a lot of pro-life people and
conservatives stumble
on they get tripped up on when they are
confronted with it which is what about
the case of rape are you telling me that
if a woman is raped and becomes pregnant
that you would you would make her carry
that baby to term and of course the
number of the percentage of abortions
that take place in the context of rape
it's less than one percent so it's it's
really just a distraction because the
libs don't want to deal with
statistically 100 of abortions which are
elective
so they bring that up and this is the
hard case
and but
the premise here is that
you can
undo the rape you can make the rape all
better you can make the rape go away if
you just kill the baby and that's a
ridiculous premise we should not accept
that premise
the woman is raped
now she's pregnant and confronted with a
choice do you kill the baby or not
the the two questions from a moral
standpoint are completely unrelated
the rape is bad the rape is a trauma the
woman is going to have to work through
that rape
spiritually psychologically perhaps
physically
that's
abortion isn't gonna fix any of that
then you have the question should the
woman kill the baby in addition to that
and by the way if the woman does kill
the baby and they're not gonna tell you
this in the pro-abortion
lecture or or class if the woman does
kill the baby she's going to have a
trauma from that too one she's going to
have to in a sense give birth to it one
way or the other you've got to get the
baby out of there and two she's going to
have the nagging guilt of the reality
that she killed the baby
so you're adding trauma on to trauma
but
even putting that aside for a second
nothing about getting the abortion is
going to in any way change the rape so
you've got to call them out on that you
say yeah i don't think that women who
have been victimized and raped should
then have the additional trauma of
committing a murder all right next
question
hey michael my name's braden i just
listened to your episode where you
talked about essentially the immorality
of a homosexual couple
adopting
a child just the concept in general my
question is what about those children
that
need a home absolutely need a home need
to be adopted what have you
and a broken home is better than no home
at all and you have a loving homosexual
couple willing to take them in and be a
caretaker
and a guardian for that child i'm just
curious your response to that thank you
well we've gotta distinguish between two
radically different forms of adoption
one is the adoption of newborn babies
and the other is the fostering of
children who are in orphanages usually
run by the state
those are very very different types of
abortion
and the libs and the radicals who want
to
redefine the family and who want to
mainstream things like single-parent
adoption or homosexual adoption
they they try to conflate the two
because it's helpful for their argument
but we i think we would all grant those
are very different types of adoption
and
in the case of the adoption of newborns
the premise of your question ceases to
make sense because what you will hear is
as you said
what about all those babies who need a
home and can't get a home in the case of
newborn adoption in the united states
that doesn't exist that's completely
made up lump that away with the
boogeyman and
bigfoot in the united states there are
an estimated 36 to 38 couples
who are trying to adopt newborn babies
for every single newborn baby put up for
adoption it is incredibly difficult to
adopt a baby in the united states it's
very expensive people wait years to do
it
friends of mine family members of mine
who have adopted babies have gone
through years and heartbreak and also
because of how difficult it is because
there's a dearth of babies
in the case of orphanages and the foster
care system that's different
because in that case
you're talking about children who have
been in terrible homes who have very
frequently been abused and neglected
children who are much much older
children who could be even in their
teenage years and so it's wonderful when
people foster those children and take
them into their own homes but that's a
just a totally different sort of
circumstance and so if you're asking me
should homosexuals
homosexual couples or throuples or
single parents be allowed to adopt
single parents of any sort of sexual
persuasion be allowed to adopt newborn
babies i would say of course absolutely
not that's insane you're a child has a
right to his natural mother and father
men and women both have something
to contribute to the rearing of children
marriage actually has a meaning and it's
the same thing that it's meant forever
and not what the libs pretend that it
means today and so no it would be wrong
to deny a child of a of a real family of
a proper marriage and that context to
grow up in just because of the
politically correct fantasies that we
live in today
but if you're asking me
is and in in that case you're saying
should the state
give an advantage to the real married
couple that wants to adopt the child or
say no we're agnostic it could be a
single mother could be a homosexual
couple or 3-0 could be whatever
in the case of the
foster care
you're saying
should homosexuals or single mothers or
whoever be allowed to take in children
who are not who are languishing in
orphanages certainly outside the context
of a marriage or outside of a family who
are much older who are not as desired in
in terms of adoption
as the newborns are that's a very
different conversation i would be much
more open to that conversation obviously
because they're they're just kind of
apples and oranges but the last thing we
should do is to conflate the two okay
before we go
let's get one question that's written
from steve michael you've probably
answered this before why do you use the
term liberal to describe the illiberal
left everything about their behavior
makes them woodrow wilson-style
progressives as i listen to your live
show right now you're contrasting the
concepts of liberalism progressive and
leftism i think you're one who strives
for precision in language why not in
this case thanks steve i am being
precise in this case there are two
schools of thought among conservatives
about liberalism some people believe
that the modern left is actually they
they're they've betrayed liberalism
they're not the real liberals we
conservatives are the real liberals
that's not my opinion libertarians
believe that classical liberals believe
that i do not believe that
some people believe that leftism
progressivism socialism even are natural
conclusions of liberalism not even just
the modern liberalism but going all the
way back to those classical liberals
those enlightenment quote unquote era
classical liberals
they think that it's not the op not a
betrayal of liberalism but the natural
conclusion of it i'm very much of that
opinion
i think that the shades of difference
between liberalism classical or modern
leftism progressivism even socialism and
marxism i think the shades of difference
are minuscule because i think those are
all rationalist ideologies that take the
individual to be the basic unit of
society that upend the traditional moral
order or deny the traditional moral
order and i think they're just not
really conservative at all and they all
kind of go in different directions but i
think the real alter they're all
different sides of the same coin or i
guess rubrics cube or something
i think the real alternative is
the conservative worldview that says the
basic unit of society is the family that
says we shouldn't just overturn all
traditions or upend all of society that
we ought to do things that we have done
we ought to recognize the moral order we
ought to recognize that there is such a
thing as the good we can know something
about the good ultimately we have
obligations to the common good and
ultimately to our highest good who is
god
that's my view okay we got the member
block of the show coming up
you do not want to miss this if you are
not a member at daily wire you've got to
head on down click the link in the
description below and join us my
producers have given me headlines of the
week
that i did not get to they've given me a
bunch of real headlines one fake
headline i've got to guess which the
fake one is plus we'll try to get to a
little bit more of your mail bag because
i always i hate you know on friday i've
got all these good mailbag questions we
don't have time to get to all of them
i'll get to more in the member block
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022